I'm really sad to say
that in some ways I think
the world has become a little harder
and has become faster.
The changes in the world,
like all challenges,
have forced us to become more creative,
have given us no alternative
but to become braver,
so more articulate about our feelings,
have made things like assertiveness
absolutely obligatory,
calling out what you want absolutely a must,
and really making sure
that you in some way make your talents known
because those days of kind of people going out
and hunting for talent,
yes, I'm sure on some level that still happens,
but it's hard, you really got to hold up a big sign
and say, "I am really good at what I do,
and I'm really, really rather wonderful.
You should look at me
because I'll be great for your team."
That is, I think, in a nutshell,
how the world has changed.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.